hey guys it's justine and today we are
unboxing the traeger 885 grill i am
so excited about this i've actually been
looking into getting a grill
and this one is perfect because not only
can you bake grill and smoke in it
you can connect it to wi-fi and control
it with an app it's basically made for
me
a huge thank you to traeger for
sponsoring this video and sending us a
grill to checkouts
jenna the top of this says that uh two
people are required for assembly
all right all right get those assembly
fingers ready this is a wood
pellet grill and what makes this also
different than a lot of normal grills
is you can take it down to a very low
temperature but also take it all the way
up to 500 degrees and can control all of
this from your phone you can also
control it on the grill too but
come on if you can control it with an
app why wouldn't you there's a safety
feature that won't let you turn it on
with the phone but you can control the
temperatures and turn it off so they
have a variety of different flavors
of wood pellets that you can get so the
ones that we have here
signature this is a maple cherry and an
artisanal
hardwood and we've got a hickory which
is a natural flavored hardwood
and on the back it'll show you what type
of things these are recommended for so
the signature is pretty much
all across the board good for basically
cooking anything to the capacity on this
is i can cook
ten chickens seven rib racks and nine
pork butts we're gonna need more friends
we are hello does anybody want to come
over and have a pork butt
uh they also sent me a hat oh that's
actually nice because the sun's in my
eyes so they actually sent me three hats
which is great you think time to unbox
your hat uh yeah we that's this is
fashion jenna
look how nicely this is packaged there's
also a little secret surprise
this little box actually turns into a
little cardboard
cabin house and our little niece loves
cardboard boxes so we're gonna turn this
into a little cabin for her afterwards
this is the first time i'm not gonna
recycle this
it's gonna be recycled into a home is
this in the shop this box says start
here
so we're gonna we're gonna do that
oh my gosh it's a note from the ceo of
traeger grylls
jeremy does everybody get that no yes we
want to thank you for choosing traeger
and letting us into your backyard you're
here you've infiltrated and i'm happy
about it
so here's our assembly guide they've
given us all the tools like i don't have
to go and hunt down some tools for my
dad
they've even put little cup holders for
you to put your
beverage of choice in this is it
i like that it comes pretty much put
together you basically only have to put
the sides on
and the legs and then you're off to the
grilling races
it's cool because traeger even has a
youtube channel that they have a bunch
of recipes on
so i'm definitely going to be checking
that out to get some grilling
inspiration
oh my gosh there's more stuff inside of
it
whoa everything is very nicely packaged
um is that english and the liver oh the
mood before use okay
whoa it's just like a never-ending
surprise
and it's cool because this is actually a
convection grill too so it'll be able to
circulate
the air and the heat to get a nice even
cook and i love
a good even cook i think this is the
point where i need to look at the
directions
it's that time now
and setup is starting now ready to be
high five before we start or
we did we did we removed all the grill
parts
and stuff okay here's the legs let's
flip this around
and lay it down and assemble
[Music]
i say we lift this up and we tighten up
those screws this is great i'm so hungry
the unfortunate reality is i still need
to go to the grocery store
to get the foods that i'm going to be
grilling so i think grilling is actually
going to happen tomorrow
there's someone coming down the driveway
oh i'm unsure
do you think they want to help us our
mom is that our mom oh that is
that's our mom mom's home so maybe she's
gonna help us with the girls go for it
just go for it
there's even wheels on this thing like
this is like all terrain
so now jenna we need to put this on i'm
gonna need your assistance
it's in look at that you guys can tell
that the sun has now
shifted slightly we did a good job well
look now this needs to go somewhere too
this is our little side table
looks like everything is all set up i'm
gonna now sync this to the app and do
the rest of the setup process
okay it's time to name the grill i've
got it all connected
sir ribs a lot stoked on smoke baby got
brisket
should i come up with a custom name yeah
what about i just grilled
oh i just grill okay
we're gonna do that all right welcome to
the wood fried revolution for true
grilling for oh man this is great yeah
give me all the notifications
send me everything we have to season our
grill this is to be used on the initial
firing only we need to prime the auger
it's priming good night
[Music]
oh my gosh it's igniting
this is our first ignition we've got
accessories
look at this fancy look how professional
goodness we've got traeger barbecue
sauces
we've got a grill cleaner all natural oh
we need these oh my goodness look an
internal temperature guide
magnetic tool hooks more barbecue sauce
pork and poultry rub wow this
is so incredible i smell it too oh good
oh it smells like a campfire oh it's
starting to get warm
it's happening
oh yeah we're up to 80 to
83 degrees
[Music]
it is the next day and we actually
covered the grill last night and
good thing because currently i'm in the
east coast and there was a downpour
so the grill is protected i have been
inside preparing a
feast i've got steaks i've got chickens
i've got cauliflower broccoli potatoes
i think i got something else as well i'm
also going to make chocolate chip
cookies for dessert there's a bunch of
recipes that i've kind of followed but
i've sort of mixed and matched some
things and i'm gonna try to make all of
these things at the same time on this
grill there's so much space in this
thing
so that kind of gives us a real
opportunity to make a bunch of different
things
at the same time i'm also gonna use this
internal temperature for the chicken
i also gotta fill up my pellets
[Music]
just got a notification from the traeger
app that my grill
is preheated now we're going to put all
of the stuff on the grill and i just
want to be completely honest with you
guys
i've never really done much grilling in
my life so i don't entirely 100
know everything about grilling so i'm
not claiming to be an expert
but what's great is with the app i feel
like it's giving me all of the knowledge
that i need to know
and you know what you live and you learn
so today
you guys are witnessing history
[Music]
i've got some of the rub on this one and
then on this guy i've got another one of
the barbecue sauces so this chicken i
have a nice little italian
seasoning marinade that my mom actually
made so this is uh this one's for my mom
got the chicken marinating in some of
the traeger barbecue sauce
there's some potatoes with a little
garlic seasoning and some
random butter that i found in the fridge
that looked kind of good so i threw it
on there
this is a parmesan broccoli cauliflower
recipe that i found on the traeger
recipes
i also threw some garlic in there
because why not oh my gosh are kabobs
too i got so much food
good luck little buddies
[Music]
now we wait
i just got a notification that my
chicken has reached the internal
temperature of 165.
grill probe 166 i was aiming for 165 so
guess what guys i'm gonna take a little
peek at it
look at this look at those little grill
marks
i think i should have put it this way i
feel like that's what you're supposed to
i put it the wrong way
i just learned something and so did you
guys
you guys aren't done yet either
everything is still cooking
i'm gonna give the chicken just a few
more minutes just because i like mine
kind of
done a little extra and then we'll take
them out and then
we'll kind of monitor everything else
that's happening in here
and then we eat the chicken
is ready it's probably done it's oh my
gosh
it's probably done this looks delicious
okay i'm gonna put this into this
chicken
look at that temp chicky
okay these are our marinated ones
i think these actually might be ready
oh my god it's incredible oh it's not
good
i think we're like freaking ready
actually
we're set i'm having my whole meal right
here
our potatoes are needing a little extra
care
they look good yeah those are pretty
much good to go look at that
it's very nice i know presentation is
everything
my feast is complete and now it's time
for a taste test
uh complete is a lie because the
potatoes are still cooking but we can
get to those after
broccoli taste test well luckily it has
a little i sit
the broccoli was incredible let's taste
this chicken so this i used to traeger
barbecue sauce on it
oh that's good it has like a little
hint of sweetness okay steak i also used
the rub and
the traeger barbecue sauce on here oh
that's good
i can't believe this is the first time
i've ever grilled i'm pretty impressed
with the outcome jen
looks good maddie is also excited let me
get a little this vegetable to see how
that cooked
this is good i put a little butter
pepper and
sea salt flakes on the kebabs i've been
looking forward to this
since yesterday when we unboxed the
thing we're gonna get a small taste of
mommy's meal okay you're ready
lay down all the way down all the way
down good boy
is that maddie approved good boy
the sun is going down so we might be
making some nighttime chocolate chip
cookies but
we have to test out the baking in this
thing super hyped about
that i'm going to finish my meal and get
ready for dessert
so good i forgot about the potatoes i
was prepping my cookies
before the sun sets oh
those look good look how nice this one
is
get over there these actually look so
good we gotta get this to 350 degrees
i should have just left them on the
baking sheet but i um i did it because i
got nervous
you can actually go into the cookie
recipe and hit make
and it'll set the timer and do
everything
basically for me there it goes begin
cook
it's happening they're already cooking
oh boy
let's go have some potatoes and wait for
our cookies oh i'm hyped
sun is going down the moon is coming up
and long ago somebody has left with the
cup
checking on the cookies oh wow
they're actually looking really good i
need to go get some sea salt to add to
the top for a little extra flavoring
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god these look incredible whoa
[Music]
some sea salt flakes
[Music]
i'm gonna let them cool off for a second
and the taste test
i mean i've never had a chocolate chip
cookie that was made on the grill
it's interesting because it has like a
slight little like smoky taste to it it
tastes so awesome with these salt flakes
oh more goodness jenna
oh yeah i'll get it on that we'll get
ill now huge thank you to traeger for
sponsoring this video
they have some incredible videos on
their youtube channel i'll put a link in
the description if you want to check
that out
and also a link to the girl that i have
if you guys want to check that out and
all of the incredible accessories that
they have to go with it
i'm going to finish up this cookie and
i'll see you guys in my next video
peace here jen which one you want oh
i'll pick one okay here we go
[Music]